[Música]
anteriormente eran antiguos lugares
espirituales hoy en día tesoros de
nuestro patrimonio esa abadía es
francesas a veces han tenido destinos
sorprendentes ubicada a 760 metros de
altitud la abadía del musandoil vigila
toda la planicia del sacia al principio
era un convento fundado en el siglo viil
de odemburgo quien heredó esta Colina de
su padre el Duque del saciar
un día Dile caminaba por el lugar como
un tarro de harina y ese día su padre le
preguntó Pero qué estás haciendo y ella
respondió le estoy dando mi ración de
harina a un pobre no tienes nada y lo
das todo bueno de pronto Nada te faltará
y fue entonces que le donó dicho lugar
hoy en día turistas excursionistas y
peregrinos se cruzan allí especialmente
para beber de su fuente conocida por sus
milagros
tenía dificultades para subir hasta
senodil y tenía sed decidió ayudarlo
golpeó la roca y en esta piedra de
arenisca donde lógicamente no debería
haber una fuente apareció una
milagrosamente
el hecho de tomar un poco en la mano y
de beberla conscientemente permite darse
cuenta de que se trata de un agua muy
dinamizada
mito o verdadera fuente beneficiosa la
Fuente fue joven cualquier caso la
leyenda del monte sandillo que se
convirtió en Un refugio para los pobres
y los enfermos y luego en una abadía
dirigida hoy en día por el padre Patrick
culler
el hombre marcado por su fe cristiana
encontró su felicidad en este lugar
quién Busca simplemente un punto de
vista encuentra su satisfacción es decir
que es un lugar que sintetiza todas las
sedes que puede tener el ser humano
a 600 kilómetros al oeste en los
confines de ayu la abadía también ha
tenido varias vidas en la Edad Media
primero fue una de las órdenes
monásticas más grandes de Europa
llegando a convertirse en la necrópolis
de la dinastía productoseney Aquí está
Ricardo Corazón de León El rey caballero
es un poco la estrella hay varias
estrellas en fonte
la figura femenina por excelencia reina
de Francia reina de Inglaterra es un
pedazo de la historia de Europa
la abadía de fontebu Es sobre todo una
historia de mujeres la tradición aquí
dictaba que la institución fuera
dirigida no por abad sino por una
abadesa que tenía autoridad sobre toda
la región
Esta es la sala del capítulo como su
nombre lo indica es un lugar donde se
toma la palabra porque se leen los
capítulos de la regla de San Benito es
un espacio bastante grande donde las
monjas se sentaban en muebles aquí había
asientos donde podían sentarse en
diferentes lugares la abadesa presidía y
desde aquí dirigía la sala daba órdenes
y administraba Justicia
pero la revolución le puso fin a la
tradición y la abadía se convirtió en
una prisión acogió hasta 2500
prisioneros que trabajaban y se alojaban
en inmensos dormitorios y en estas
celdas
[Música]
activo el mecanismo que permite abrir
las puertas de todas las celdas
aquí vivía el prisionero en la noche
después del trabajo dormía en un colchón
de paja ubicado aquí era rudimentario lo
que es conmovedor en esos espacios es
que se ve que anotaron los meses El
tiempo pasa deja huella
la prisión cerró sus puertas en los años
60 y desde entonces se transformó en un
lugar de exposiciones culturales
bastante insólito
más al sur cerca de Monterrey está
abadía tuvo un destino aún más
sorprendente con 900 años falmaní es una
de las abadías mejor conservadas de
Francia estas piedras albergaron una
comunidad de monjes cistercienses
durante más de seis siglos En ese
momento la abadía era una de las más
ricas del sur de Francia
Este es el corazón espiritual de la
abadía es el lugar de vida de los monjes
Este es el refectorio en el que comían
está el escritorio donde copiaban los
manuscritos es muy importante hace parte
del trabajo de los monjes también está
la sala capitular donde se reunían cada
mañana después de la primera misa
[Música]
pero tras la época de los monjes
sistercienses la iglesia encontró otra
función
[Música]
el lugar fue reconvertido en una bodega
gigantesca estos enormes barriles
llamados tonales hoy en día están vacíos
pero sirvieron para almacenar miles de
litros de vino sorprendente para un
lugar sagrado
lo que es sorprendente son los barriles
para mí todavía tienen un alma algo me
estremezco un poco en este lugar
la iglesia solo fue utilizada como
bodega a partir de la Revolución
Francesa pero La Vid siempre ha hecho
parte del paisaje los monjes la
plantaron alrededor desde su instalación
hace 900 años lo que le ha dado a
balmagné el apodo de catedral de los
viñedos